as we look back at this past year the
push continues right now
to get as many nevadans vaccinated as
possible bianca holman shows us how a
health clinic
is helping the most vulnerable get the
services they need
[Applause]
i'm here at lutheran social services of
nevada located here on boulder highway
and this is where homeless men and women
are getting
the health resources that they so
desperately need
the parking lot here is filled with
every health resource
you can imagine the nevada homeless
alliance has items for pets
they've got bathing stations for folks
hiv screenings and clothes and shoes
but most importantly those who are
eligible are able to get the covet 19
vaccine
physical assistance students from toro
university nevada were on hand answering
questions
providing health screenings and
administering the shot
we've always been very committed to
going out and helping our community
so we've been doing events like this for
a long time so great for now that things
are opening up and people are more
immunized and our numbers are going down
so great that we can get back to
providing medical care but also
providing vaccines
i think vaccines are going to be the
real key to getting las vegas back on
its feet
those 55 and older with underlying
conditions received the one dose
johnson johnson vaccine and we're told
more clinics like this are planned for
the future
reporting from boulder and land bianca
holman 8 news now